hello and welcome to part 8 of my SEO
tutorial in this tutorial we're gonna be
talking about some of your website's
structural and functional important
issues when it comes to search engine
optimization so one of the main concepts
here is going to be loading time usually
measured in milliseconds and the
question here is obviously how long is
it taking for users to load your web
page now I speak at least from my
experience and I'm sure a lot of you
guys can relate if your computer is
running like really really slow it kind
of like makes you mad right it makes you
uncomfortable and it like to me if my
computer is running slow I get kind of
pissed off exercise the same thing with
your website if your if your website is
very slow it results in your users not
having a very good experience so
generally your website's loading time is
of importance now obviously loading time
is kind of can be a toss up often with
other like features of your website
first so with us for example our loading
time is usually pretty pretty large
write like this that wasn't so bad but
say we want to load let's load up like
this stock here we're still waiting so
there you see that loading time for this
page was I wasn't really timing it but a
little bit over a second probably but
and that was just for this stock but
then you know it loads up this
javascript program that allows users to
do all kinds of stuff with it so it's
it's kind of user friendly even though
it did take a while to load it's just
kind of like one of those things where
you have to decide you know is it better
to load a little bit longer or load less
data or whatever and like same thing
with your games but some of the thoughts
stuff that you can do is cache various
things like your images even like text
and in this case like stuff that you're
loading from a database you can cache
that as well so the only things that
needs to load maybe is brand new stuff
that has happened since the last cache
process and really this is kind of like
something that you're pretty much always
going to battle
as long if you have like a web
application so as the web application
grows and even as your website grows
you're gonna constantly be trying to
make it as efficient as possible while
at the same time retaining you know all
the good stuff that you wanted to keep
right I like to think that Google has it
in mind that depending on what's
actually being loaded here is somewhat
important right if you're just loading a
bunch of static HTML and you've got a
really long loading time then you've
probably got really poor hosting in
relation to how many people are visiting
your website and so I think that
probably is gonna rank more negatively
than if you've got like maybe some sort
of game or something that's just gonna
take a little bit to load right and then
time on site you know they'll probably
take that into consideration as well
like how long was the loading time
versus how much time are they spending
on that page I imagine is important to
them and along those same lines when it
comes to loading time is you know what
kind of hosting do you have for your
website so if you have shared hosting
for example you're usually sharing a
server with somebody else and so if they
get a lot of visitors at one time and
you get a lot of visitors at one time
all of a sudden you can get it
overloaded we run out of RAM go into
like swap memory and your website is
just almost grinding to a halt all right
and so that can be pretty bad so so if
as your website's traffic increases you
want to also obviously increase your
hosting because it will affect that will
affect your loading time and the user
experience as well and it's usually a
good idea to upgrade before you need to
upgrade right
I mean web hosting is pretty darn cheap
these days so it kind of moves you to go
ahead and stay a little bit ahead of
where you are at the moment now as with
all of these these topics that I bring
up as far as SEO is concerned you know
you know one thing isn't going to hold
you back from you know it's not going to
kill you if your website loading time is
four seconds right if you've got
everything else going just perfect you
know you're going to still have a great
ranking it's more of the accumulation of
a lot of negativity or the accumulation
of a lot of really good things that
that's that's how you're gonna make or
break your SEO so along those same lines
of loading time and page structure and
all that comes html5 with some of the
changes of html5 probably one of the
more basic differences is in the past
you had a header and a footer to your
website and basically the header was you
know all this stuff right the nav bar
the banner and anything above that and
then the footer was basically all this
stuff down here right in this in this
grayish box that that's the footer and
that was the only header and footer that
a website even really had but now a
header and footer actually with html5
you've got a you know your website's
header and footer then you've got
content header content footer and the
footer isn't necessarily at the bottom
of the content either it could come at
the top just whatever's labeled this
footer and actually Google is going to
use what's within your footer sometimes
so you want to go ahead and add footer
text as well so if you've got like posts
you want to have a header and a footer
obviously the other nice addition to
html5 is no longer do you have to have
light like in the past it was everything
was like a div tag right so you got a
div a class and you give it a little
class name and you could specify CSS
rules to it but now with html5 it's not
really a div anymore you just call it
and you just make up your own tag
basically and so you can use that tag to
actually mean something more than just
dip right and you can have actual you
know content tags post tags author tag
all this kind of stuff and put her tag
header tag that kind of stuff and that
helps Google read your website and
understand what's going on because again
when Google looks at your website Google
sees you know source code of your
website so it's a little bit harder for
Google to like read through your site so
again it's just a matter of
accommodating Google so you can actually
you know label what everything actually
is
with them another pretty important
factor these days especially and only
becoming more important is likeö
responsiveness of your website so how
easily are people able to view your
website on various screens now at the
same time it's important right now I
also think it's losing importance and
it's going to be less important in the
future and what I mean by that is like
if you visit a non responsive website on
your phone if you have like an
up-to-date phone and you visit it yet
it's still a non responsive website your
phone is actually pretty good at
displaying just the content and then as
time goes on as more people are using
html5 and stuff it's html5 is kind of
further future and your phone will be
able to display html5 how it wants to
display it so it's almost like we're in
this transitional period right now where
it is really important but I think in
the future every like your devices will
automatically display the website
however you know they see fit
so and you probably even choose how you
want to display a website I bet it's
pretty gonna be crazy in the future guys
but anyway it's still important
especially if you feel a lot of your
viewers like if you have like a social
site or something or a blog chances are
people are going to be viewing it on all
kinds of different screens you know you
might have 30% on a computer 30% on a
tablet 30% on a phone right and so you
want it to be responsive so here I've
got a couple examples one is my Centex
website it's not very responsive so like
if I move this around
not too much changes you know like the
the main content here I move around but
it won't it's not very responsive of a
website but I have another website my
personal website here it's very
responsive and so like we could we'll
move to let's put on this page here and
so you can see that you know there's a
bunch of stuff here now I'm actually
kind of curious I forget what happens to
these images they might not they might
not work out but we'll see but anyways
as you squish this you can see that it's
got you know basically it will screen
view and then as you come in its got
about like you know an 800 by 600 screen
view so what kind of squish some stuff
up squishes up the text everything's
fitting in there so far and then you
basically the mobile view and again it's
pushed up the pictures it squishes up
the video in that picture too so no
matter what someone's viewing this
website on they're able to view it very
nicely and then you know the buttons
obviously they went here and stuff so so
like this is an example of a highly
responsive website that's viewable and
basically anything
so keep that in mind as well as you're
building your website but you can also
consider you know what are people
actually doing when they visit your
website like I've got a website that's
dedicated to pure gaming it's a computer
game you can only play it on a computer
and the only time you would ever want to
visit our web app is if you are playing
the game so to me it's like well it's
not very important that we have a really
responsive website
it just seems like a waste of time so
you can kind of take into consideration
that and plus I like I was saying in the
future as long as you've converted to
html5 and even if you have and I bet it
won't be that big of a deal as the
device itself kind of Orient's the page
but still today it does matter it will
matter for your ranking and you want to
keep that in mind now the next few
things as far as structure or even
loading time and really like the path on
your website is concerned how you want
to orient your website a lot of times
there's it's just a huge case of trial
and error and so one of the most useful
tools in my opinion for building a
website and kind of structuring and
orienting your website and building
content that people are actually
engaging themselves in would be some
sort of analytics and in my opinion
Google Analytics just kind of they take
the cake on everything Google Analytics
is very very good so in the next video
we're gonna be just diving into Google
Analytics and some of the basic stuff
that you can do within Google Analytics
but it's it's very useful to have highly
recommend it so I definitely suggest
that you watch the next video as always
thanks for watching